what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to a
fresh and fit clip
titled the strip club and jewelry store
awakened the better bachelor before i
begin do not forget to like
comment and subscribe at 15 000
subscribers let me know what i should do
because i'm gonna do something cool
but like i can't think of anything yet
so let me know what i should do
okay i really like the better bachelor
i've seen him on a couple
um clips on fresh and fit
and i actually really enjoy his
commentary
can you tell us your rp awakening story
going down memory lane
[Music]
no
[Laughter]
my my red pill kind of came in
increments okay
you know you don't i don't i mean
everybody most guys had
one thing that was like that's it i'm
out
um or i i'm looking at life the wrong
way um i
i was pretty much raised in a very
traditional family which is hey
you get older you do the right thing you
get a good job you're a good man you're
supportive
you care for your family and you get
married and i did that
and but before that um
when i when i worked in like a strip
club for example
you'd see women that i mean there are
guys coming in and dumping a lot of cash
and some of them were good looking but
they didn't come from a frame of
strength and
customer frame right they were like i'm
so lucky to have you put your boobs in
my face like here's some money
and women women view guys like that as
as weak and needy and it's very
unattractive
me as the dj on the other hand i'm like
will you shut up and let me play my
music and just get out of my booth i
don't want to look i don't care about
your outfit
yes your boobs look fine go but because
because i had set a frame of
of i i wouldn't even call i just because
i was
who i was and i wasn't kissing their ass
um they looked at me more serious and
because of that i think
they looked at me as a more powerful or
a more selective male more importantly
they had to respect you right right if
they didn't they're dancing to some bad
music
thanks i don't remember who uh played it
it might have been a bare naked monk
or bare naked ladies or something but it
was like uh metallica all of a sudden no
it was like i'd play something like
there's
uh it was something like the the uh
the strip when the stripper is crying or
something there was a song that was
it was all about like i love it when the
stripper is crying or the dancers crying
like i'd play them something that's just
awful no beat to it
but um that was part of it because i
would see how the men
that really wanted beautiful women that
treated them very well
uh were customers like you said and all
their boyfriends were
you know they were dealers they were
guys that used them for money now how
about that
how about you know you'd have a a very
attractive woman who granted is a dancer
but
the guy she's going home with she's like
oh here's your allowance or here's my
money for the night
and i'm like how is it that this guy
that treats her horrible
has no money and she's the one giving
him the money and
and she's happy to date him it was
because of his mindset of look
i don't need you like i'll get another
dancer to pay me and as weird as that
sounds you kind of go
i guess it works and the other thing is
when i let me know in the comments why
do you guys find that as a trend
because i could definitely see it now
that
they explain it but i actually don't
know why that is i worked in the jewelry
industry
um when i worked in the jewelry industry
i was a manager
of a lot of employees and many of them
were women
and most of them were um either married
or had boyfriends
and i was out being the manager i did
not i mean
these are my employees you don't flirt
with them you're not really nice with
them you're
but you'd have interesting conversations
um but it's not like friday night at the
club
and what was interesting is a lot of
them would flirt with me
and some of them would be even very
suggestive with me
and i'm like but you're married and or
you're very
christian or yeah in one case you're
very
muslim yeah and you kind of go arms
going like
but you're married and you're happy like
they're always like oh my husband did
why are you flirting with me why are you
even looking my way like i'm giving out
zero vibes yeah and then you realize
well i'm giving out zero vibes
and you know you're you're the man of
star of the show
so the idea is the less effort
you put in the more
these girls want you so it was that
first started me on the path
and then um it
i i think be wait baby come here
between that and then kind of seeing
what feminism is doing which is the best
thing that's ever happened to men by the
way
if you want to get yeah if you want
casual bedroom fun guys oh feminist
feminism is actually very good for this
jeff's your turn man
feminism yeah if you're if you're gonna
get married well you know what though it
was it wasn't not bad before
feminism anyway i mean it may not have
been as bad yeah but you still lost your
do you feel like it's true that the less
effort a guy puts in
the more girls he gets why are you
laughing
do you feel like it's true that the more
effort a guy
puts in the less girls he gets and the
less effort a guy puts in
the more girls he gets
so how how did that work with me
did you because i feel like you put an
effort
when we first started talking yeah
you don't you don't
you flew me to houston did
well you also weren't super pushy though
okay you don't have any commentary on
this am i not supposed to know this
am i watching the wrong videos
okay babe you can go back to the living
room now just close the door on your way
out
i'm studying something
sure so he seems to think it's true on
some
level but he flew me out to i don't know
women would still step out on you um
divorce rates 60
to 70 depending on the country women
file so all feminism
feminism has done it said hey you know
what it's not shameful to have an only
fans
it's not shameful to be a sugar baby no
this is so
true i was thinking about this the other
day feminine we had it so
good before feminism oh we didn't have
to work
we could just chill at the house cook
clean fine whatever right
and then and nowadays you know how easy
that would be
half of our appliances and stuff are
automatic
they're automatic so it's not like
you're hand washing dishes anymore
or you're hand washing laundry you're
throwing that [ __ ] in the
machine and now these people are saying
go to work
why i don't wanna i wanna be on my
youtube channel at the house
and then okay the other thing
like before you had to be me like a lot
more people were married before they had
sex
and that's like a lot better for women
because you have
the security of knowing a guy spent like
10 grand five whatever it is on the ring
in order to like lock you down
where now it's like they don't have to
give you anything it's not
shameful to shake your ass punani up on
the
up on the stage but ladies this is okay
it's empowering and men are like
thank you like men used to have to you
know men used to have to
get married before they even had access
to the bedroom or in some cases
now it's like it's friday you know and
for the
for the guys that do learn game and for
guys that are still out there hunting
it's not easy to get in the position but
you can get yourself up to where you can
get a shot at it
those guys they're doing very well and
no that's really true this is why i
think that dating is easier for a guy
than a girl because if you're
born an unattractive girl and an
unattractive guy and you want like a
certain caliber of partner
if you're a girl it's not like you can
work hard and achieve it you can like
get you know like work out on your body
and stuff but if you don't have a pretty
face you're not gonna get like
the type of partner that you could
hypothetically want but a guy if he gets
enough money and works out enough like
girls don't really care and learns how
to talk to girls
then for the others it's kind of like
man i don't waste my time so it's a
blessing and a curse at the same time so
all this kind of combined i'm like
there's a lot of stuff i want to talk
about
and a lot of the people that that do
talk about these things
um can be very negative and for me i'm
just like
why don't hate the player hate the game
yeah just like let's talk about this but
we don't have to jump down into the into
the mud
with you know the the feminists say all
men must die or
yeah men are pigs i'm like okay you do
you you you be unhappy you roll around
the mud you hate life
i'm good like i'm happy so let's talk
about this from maybe a happy place of
hey if you do well guys and and you set
yourself up for success
and you have the right frame of mind
yeah the only guys that are mad about it
are guys that don't
want to put in the work to be honest
you'll win even if
women the rest of your life tell you to
f off and they hate you you're like i
don't
care yeah like i'm good i got money i
get to travel i get to
go to southeast asia or someplace where
men are still appreciated
and i'm like okay i want to take all
this and talk about it yeah and that's
just where it started
i'm never going to ghost out of society
like i'm never a fully black pill
um here's the thing i'm i've met
amazing women i've got amazing women in
my life my mother my sister um there are
there are good women out there i think
and i think when you pull the plug on
that you just say you know what i'm
evaporating now
i i say this before i buy the land and
actually disappear from society
one day like let's check out what oh
he's gone but
um i think it's being smart but never
say no to an opportunity
yeah you know and and as as men
especially
if you're a strong intelligent
well-financed
um good mindset man
you're going to get attention now it may
not be from somebody you appreciate you
know like you might be
i'm i'm not really into her you will get
attention and as i always say like
you don't turn down somebody setting a
cheese pizza in front of you
like you don't go i love cheese pizza
thank you but no because
i swore you know keep your options open
and and
uh so i that's the way i look at it i
guess going back to your rp awakening so
you worked at the club
was there anything else that made you
like wake up as well besides the club
well my own my own relationships your
own relationships yeah that's been
married before right yeah
i was married um the nicer not not
necessarily to her because
we went apart because she fell in love
with work and she had some other issues
and i i've shared that on the story
i kind of won't rehash it's not that
exciting yeah um but i think a big
portion of it is that
the night the the the weird thing is
like if i said to a woman look
uh like i'd like to casual date and i'm
not into the long term
and i'm not in like i'm just not in a
good
place where i'm ready to settle down
like let's just keep this fun and we'll
have fun
um and i genuinely meant it those were
the women that are like
i miss you how are you why didn't you
answer my text
what's going on yeah but the woman that
would like text me and i'm like oh man
i've been waiting to hear from her for
so long and
and i really think a lot about her you
do that stupid move where you text back
right away or within five minutes and
it's a paragraph three times longer than
what she sent you
and i have a theory that it's literally
because the girl is like slightly out of
his league
and it's not necessarily that he like
texted later or whatever
that it's literally because that girl is
like better looking and like on a
higher level than the rest and like
where he's on a higher level than the
girls that like
are saying i miss him whatever and all
of a sudden you say um
yeah um and then all of a sudden you say
man
why is it all the ones i like don't like
me or they're not tired of me or i'm the
nice guy
or i'm boring or and they went off and
chased somebody else gotcha
so that was part of it and then yeah
like you you you mentioned there with
the jewelry store this you i would so i
didn't know you worked at a jewelry
store yeah so i've had
like i've always been one of those just
like where's the money that's where i
was when i was younger okay because i i
i i didn't know what i wanted to do okay
i still don't just so you know
i i really thought i was going to come
back and do this as kind of a hobby and
then i'd be going back to be an engineer
or something else you never know
that's why i say never shut down an
opportunity because you never know what
can happen in life but ceo
yeah yeah control every opportunity
exactly exactly
so um hey there
so um so working in the jewelry store
was part of that the other was watching
guys
or excuse me working the jewelry store
and seeing the employee or the employees
kind of flirting with me and that kind
of thing that
and they were married that was part of
it the other part is
when you'd see women and there were many
of them where the guy would come in
and he'd be like oh i'd like to see a
one carat die or half care whatever it
was he picked out
something around this ring and the
dummies brought her
and she's like um i don't like that one
i went ooh
and the price kept going up and the size
kept going and you could see the guy
like
like just doing dude i can't yeah and
then we'd kind of take him aside and be
like okay what what can you do have you
thought about financing it's
like it's all this whole game yeah and
and i realized like a lot of
some women guys had come back she didn't
like it wasn't big enough
am i the only girl that's cheap out
there
because in all honesty i mean obviously
you want like a big ring but like
if we like talked about investing that
money into like a house or something
i i really would not care um do you have
anything
other guys would be like no she broke up
with me after i and it's like wow
can you can you imagine you're
basically saying i will commit the rest
of my life to you because you're an
amazing woman and i love you and she's
like
it's too small it's like just like that
when you see that enough you're like
they don't i've never thought about it
from that perspective as a jeweler to
get like that rp from the other side
where you see men spending
crazy amounts of money willing to commit
to a woman and we had one check on the
show that pawned the guys ring off
actually yeah she did
and you know there's a there's a point
where you're like
where even if again like you guys say
like date but
have fun but just bail out yeah um just
don't own
right exactly there there's a point
where you realize that that
they're they're almost renting you
like hey you know you gotta i've noticed
a pattern though
a lot of the people that do these talk
shows and talk about dating and are red
pilled
tend to have a pattern of picking the
wrong woman
woman because i mean just logically
it's not like all women are bad and
there's marriages that laugh
last 50 60 years with no infidelity
where people are very loyal
and it just seems like a lot it's
interesting that a lot of these like
people that really are not into that are
like red pills or whatever
have a tendency to really
pick the wrong girls hey you're gonna
and that's why a lot of times like i've
said if guys don't have any luck
there's a couple places you can go i
always think it's hey hit the gym get
healthy
maybe learn a little game if you want to
get out there there's always that way
the other other way you can go is just
make a mad stack of cash
yep and then when you really want to
hang out with somebody
friday night and and and then it's done
there's you know you're going to get
lucky at the end of that date
you have a good time um you know she
she's not
gonna some other dude's not gonna be
walking by and she's like oh he's fine
in the club
and next thing you know you're like
where's that girl i was talking to and
she drifted off yeah
she's there and you know some people
frown on it but hey
feminism says it's okay sex positive
like do not shame women for wanting to
be you know garden tools
that's it so i feel like time is very
important and as well when you said that
a lot of guys i know that are very high
value are very like successful
they say you know what my time is
valuable i could spend
100 or maybe you know 200 bucks
on a date or i can use my time for an
hour
just pay her that because i'm worth like
a thousand dollars an hour sure so just
give her a little something
and then i'm up back to business right
so i get it time is very i mean at the
cost of what your soul
this is what i always say valuable and
they're willing to say you know what
your parents will leave and then get
what you want and then you're about to
business yeah i mean you take the the
ladies that you had here the other night
the one i caught monday morning that i
messaged you about yeah this thing that
was over here
are bits yeah yeah miss miss sweaty
armpits had to change her shirt
anyway these guys were grilling this
woman so hard she was like i'm sweating
through
and had to change her shirt so
castle over here so so so she goes and
swaps out her shirt she comes back and
then when they say
how much does a man like you know for
your guy
and and one thing i would rephrase that
what what is the
what is the the base level guy that you
would date instead of what is your dream
guy
or you know because every guy's dream
guy is like
yeah yeah so it's like what what is the
man's minimum
that he must meet but she's like 1
million to five million
dollars a year what
oh my god let me let me share something
with you a man that's worth a million to
five million
he's meeting you know he's meeting
social circles
and well-to-do people that are would
never be caught dead in a nightclub
in a little dress shaking their booty
around the floor yeah that ain't you
sweetheart that's not gonna happen yeah
um and she was 30. oh was she because i
when they went down the line she didn't
mention her age no she didn't she
yeah she avoided that question yeah she
did she was like 22
28. so anyway like she just jumped past
that question so 32.
she's she's our i mean uh 31 i think
okay so so here's the thing
i'm not saying she will find a man that
finds her beautiful she will find it
she's not
the wall yeah the wall's mobile i've
seen 23 year olds you're like
oh yeah and then i've seen 40 year olds
like yeah she's fine
yeah yeah so so that's why i'm always
careful to make sure that i
i say it's adjusting based on the woman
yeah right but she was
she was an attractive woman she had a
good shape on her good figure but she
wants a mill and a half
well the guy that's got a million and a
half that just wants to party and have a
good time
you had this thing here at 22. you got
this thing
right you got you got people out of the
club thousands of them
that are young 20s and she's now in her
young 30s
so and that's what a lot of a lot of
girls just think they can just be pretty
and
impress these guys that are making that
kind of money
but i'm sorry guys that
i know guys don't care about your money
but guys also don't want to be around
someone that's an
idiot you're kind of you're running out
of time like
what i think i don't remember the
original question we were talking about
but
i think what happens over time is that
they start here when they're young and
they're pretty and they're
oh life is fun and as they age
they're the chance that they're going to
get that
top top guy it's it's like putting out
fresh cream
and you're like there's beautiful fresh
cream it's perfect
and really she should be looking for the
best man they'd be like i want to buy
this yeah
but instead they're screwing around and
everything and that cream's just sitting
there it's kind of getting a little
curdled
next thing you know you got cottage
cheese i think a lot of women if they
understood that
80 of the women go for 20
of the guys i'm pretty sure i think a
lot of women would move differently if
they realized
that these guys are talking to like a
million different girls but a lot of
girls really don't know and she's like
why is my man
yeah and they none of them ever none of
them ever get there
[Music]
make sure okay i think my mic's working
i'm gonna be so mad if this didn't
record um let me know in the comments
if you agreed with my analysis what you
think i missed
and don't forget to subscribe i'll talk
to you guys next time